a lot of you remember the uh
dirty women march that happened the day
after president trump's
inauguration
when you have
dirty women like madonna and others at
least madonna said she
dreamed uh or thought of blowing up the
white house and
they had this judge this woman
well jack's last name josh who it
sounded like she was on
pcp or something
actually jazz sound like she was on
drugs it was uh but it brought out the
dirty women of america
some people were saying that that was
sponsored by george soros and others and
that people were being paid to be there
i have with me david pakman
host and exactly the producer of the
national syndicated david
pacman
show
a radio show with a popular podcast and
youtube channel
and david said you know he just agreed
with that he wrote an article
um
with the huffington post
trump is
bamboozled
by alternative facts he says
dirty women march he didn't call it
dirty but i do
dirty women march
protesters were not paid
by
george soros and others and i'm skyping
with david david good morning sir thank
you for coming on
thank you yeah i mean i'm curious you
know ad hominems atta aside like dirty
women that doesn't even make sense to
engage on that but when you say some
people are saying that the protesters
were paid i mean i'd like to hear what
people are saying that specifically who
is saying that when you hear some of the
conservative leadership
and conservative media saying that they
were paid
uh to to our protest
i do know that they but who who is that
i do know that there are times when
protesters
are paid to be i used to work for a
union at one time
and i used to at one time help organize
the protests
against conservatives or
or businesses and so i do know how they
operate but it has been said how do you
know that they were not paid
jesse this i'm i'm having a hard time
believing we're even having this
conversation on your program because so
far what you've said is
how do i know the protesters weren't
paid because
people would say they would not have
said they were paid in your other
protests you worked on years ago
according to you would pay protesters
this is like if i say hey donald trump
is beating melania every every night and
you say to me well how do you know that
and i say can you disprove that donald
trump is beating melania every night i
mean you're asking me
to to defend something which is the
default in other words if you're making
the extraordinary claim that protesters
have been paid provide some evidence you
haven't even named anybody in your
article you write that the dirty women
march
protesters when you said women are but
we they call themselves nasty women
and so i don't know what's the
difference between dirty women and nasty
but uh you say that they were not paid
since you wrote this and you're here
what are you talking about there's no
how do you know
they were paid this is what we call
burden of proof jesse and i would assume
that that you know this as someone who's
been in this world for a long time
if i make an assertion that is an
assertion that is not supported by fact
it is incumbent upon me to provide
evidence and again you've presented no
evidence that anyone was paid other than
saying
some protests you at some point worked
on paid people allegedly and that there
are some people who you will not name
that say people were paid that's not
evidence it's not unusual nowadays i
remember when they had that protest in
ferguson
and all those radical liberals
came out the children of the lie and
they protested
and
they were later they did not get paid so
they start
protesting against the folks who have
promised
to pay them
that they had not gotten paid remember
the black lives matter the radical black
lives matter group and those votes
i don't know i want to say no i want to
believe ferguson were protesting against
those who said that they didn't get paid
i mean i just don't whatever i don't
understand what you just said it has
nothing to do with the women's march it
just again if you can present
any evidence that protesters were paid
at the women's march of january 21st i
would love to hear it
i want to move on because of time
you have no evidence i mean i thought
you had no evidence right so you're
admitting you have no idea i thought you
had evidence that they were not paid
apparently you don't uh let me ask last
night
last night
milo so there's no evidence there's no
okay we're moving on with no evidence
last night milo was scheduled to speak
at uc berkeley
and the radical children of the lie came
out of the woodwork and
and uh just created a riot
uh setting fire throwing rocks and
stones at the buildings and
attacking supporters of milo what do you
think about that
i'm against any violence of that kind
you know i think that uh i don't even
know why my opinion matters i mean i i
had nothing to do with that i'm against
starting fires smashing windows and
using smoke bombs which is what i'm
reading people did i also though think
that president trump
is stepping in a very dangerous
direction by tweeting he tweeted that uh
because milo didn't speak he threatened
to take away federal funding from burke
from uc berkeley
it was a law enforcement decision to get
milo out for his own safety so i think
trump should spend more time maybe
reading which it's not
clear he does much of and less time
watching fox news and tweeting a live
commentary because whether or not this
was a law enforcement decision for
milo's own safety the reason that uh
president trump did that because
uh in america today
children or people who are on the side
of good have been attacked and are being
attacked over the last eight years
because we had a
far left liberal socialist
uh
anti-white anti-american president in
the white house
trump tweeted threatening to take away
funding from uc berkeley
because there are people who don't want
to hear from milo i mean again if
anybody's going to be mad at at somebody
at uc berkeley it should be with the
police there because it was their
decision for milo's safety that he not
speak are you mad at uc berkeley police
or who are you mad at uc berkeley is
against
free speech and because they receive
taxpayer dollars they have a
responsibility to protect free speech so
you're saying that the police
speech that's a pretty strong anti-law
enforcement point of view for someone
like you to take david because it was
the police decision right when when uh
when uc berkeley are not protecting
people like marlow and others
then the government has a right
to withhold
funding they did protect them they
protected themselves
by getting him out of there i mean none
of these arguments are making any sense
thank god that donald trump is doing
that the greatest president on this side
of heaven
hold on back in a moment david hold on
[Music]
hold me
baby
[Music]
so i'm talking i'm skyping with david
patman and he wrote an article for the
in the huffington post
trump is
bamboozled by alternative facts
he says women's march protesters were
not paid
and it's been written in breitbart and
other
media sources that is known that george
sorrow sorrows and others have
paid for these rallies and supported
these rallies and paid these votes
occupy wall street
um
the
so-called mothers for the movement
remember those black women who failed
their sons like trayvon martin and
others and now their sons are dead and
they want to blame it on so-called
racism
uh
black lives mothers movement black lives
matter so it's it's it's known that
george sorrows and others
are paying and how paid they supposed to
go out and be destructive
uh david the woman's mart that dirty
woman's march website had a huge list of
partners
including
planned parenthood
environmentalists
feminists anti-gun group muslims occupy
wall street radical homosexuals and
transgenders
unions nw aacp
the national urban league i wanted to
ask
were
were there any good and decent and
honest organizations that supported the
dirty mart women's march
listen jesse that's a sort of bogus
question obviously you don't think that
those organizations are good and i'm not
going to be able to convince you that
they are i think here's the key point
the stories about george soros paying
i need you to protesters that question
for me were there any good and decent
organizations supporting the dirty women
march
it's it's a silly question because the
organizations you listed i think are
good but you don't so where where will
that conversation get us here's the main
point you listed breitbart etc
all of those allegations go back to an
article written by azra nomani which
appeared on the new york times website
she was asked directly after breitbart
and all of the other right-wing news
sites said look soros paid them do you
think
that these protesters were paid to
protest the writer of the article said
quote i definitely do not conclude that
the people marching were paid to do so
full stop that's it
and and that says what to you that's
just another personal opinion how do you
know that that person
is challenging jesse david the point of
another person's opinion david the point
is you do not david i don't want to wait
that the protesters were david i just
got that from
omani who says she doesn't believe
that the protesters were paid so by let
me see if i can explain this by citing
breitbart you're citing osra nomani who
doesn't think the protesters were paid
david i'm turning your mic off you
cannot speak over me
david we need to have a comment session
you can't speak we're running out of
time and every time i
uh attempt to ask a question or present
something to you you just run it off at
the mouth it doesn't work that way
because your skype configuration no it's
not it's not that we've not had that
problem
any other time at any other time
um
i want to know what is your proof
that
first let me ask this because i wanted
to ask you about donald trump did you
did you vote for donald trump you
support president trump
what do you think i don't know i don't
want to assume that you're doing about
the enduring march
the women's during the march rally did
you support him
no i did not and why not
oh there's no policies of trump's
my uh other than some very minor
overlaps with bernie sanders that that i
agree with him on
and so you want to believe
that george because you're one of them
you want to believe that joyce soros and
others
did not support or paid
protesters at the during tomorrow rally
you have
no
proof at all that they were not paid but
yet you wrote an article saying that
they were not paid
jesse do you understand the difference
between
saying they weren't paid and saying
there's no evidence they were paid is
that a difference that you understand
i cited you so breitbart and others who
have said that they were paid do you
agree with that that uh the left is more
violent and oppressive than the right
no i don't jesse and why not
because there's no evidence to suggest
that so you have not seen the violence
and protest for an example on the
inauguration day on president donald
trump there were
violence uh people were setting at least
one car limousine he was set on fire
there in washington dc and other areas
was that did you see that violence
i feel like this is a clinic in logical
fallacies do you understand how did you
see that what happens into violence does
not allow us to make any generalizations
about whether liberals or conservatives
have a higher or lower tendency towards
violence is that again conceptually as
well do you remember
do you remember when the tea party
rallies were happening
i i generally remember there were no
violence
that's not true
no you had you had the left objectively
conservatives are more violent because i
can point to one incident of tea party
violence i would be committing the same
logical fallacy your commitment you have
your time believing this is a serious
conversation you had the children of the
left
coming out and attacking the tea party
and pretending that it was members of
the tea party itself just as we saw
during the campaign presidential
campaign with president trump and
hillary clinton you had the children of
the left the children of the lie going
to president trump's rallies
and attacking the supporters but the
liberal media reported it as though
it was supporters of trump and you're in
denial about that
i i'm your mike's cutting in and out of
jesse i don't know if there was a
question in there
let me take a break back in a
moment is all that i can give
to you
love
is more than just a game
for two
two
in love can make it take my heart and
please don't break it love
was made for me
[Music]
about me
[Music]
i want to make it clear that um
again i'm talking to david pakman
he is
pretending
that
he's having problem with this uh skype
uh
lying there see how he can hear me now
real clear no problem hearing
and still getting out even right now
he is uh pretending that he can't hear
me in order to waste time and not really
answer questions here david do you
remember the 99
march with the occupy wall street
there in new york and around the country
remember when that was happening
i do and do you remember uh
there were reports of sexual assaults
and rape and
defecation on police cars and
they just
destroy the areas that they protest in
and then during donald trump's
run against hillary clinton in chicago
chicago they had to
shut down one of his rallies
because the
children of the lie on the left
uh
uh protested and threatened and it got
so out of control and that was on video
do you remember any of those things
i do
and were that
um
radical left
violence
have you ever have you seen anyone on
the right
carry on in that manner of course of
course right-wingers are violent all the
time we have countless instances of uh
gun-toting right-wingers protesting
violence hate crimes etc i just is this
really what your audience wants to hear
i mean this doesn't seem interesting
david you have never seen
people on the right on the side of good
acting in that way so you're being
dishonest
just what you're doing is intellectually
just as in your heart
on the right on the side of good which
allows you to take anyone on the right
who's violent and you say well they're
not on the side of good so they don't
count i mean these are really sort of
like amateurish um distractions that you
use david
you're not just as you're not um
giving us any proof that the dirty women
marched protesters were not paid
you're not being honest in your
discussion in your dialogue now sorry
jesse i think you just don't understand
burden of
you're not being honest about
the um
in the uh skype
situation you have no problems happening
there but i appreciate you coming on you
are a typical liberal and we got what we
expected from you
i think that we certainly got what we
expected from you that's for sure no
facts misunderstanding of the burden and
you just you're just honest about the
whole dialogue thank you for coming on
man
not dishonest prove me prove it thanks
david um
it was an interesting interview what do
you think about it it felt really
shallow yeah i sure did that it was just
he got hung up on this uh
paid unpaid and
then he and then he's citing hate crimes
which are a total farce
because you were talking about the left
being more hateful and violent than the
right
and he cited hate crimes or something
and then he cited people who are toting
guns and calling that violence that
didn't make any sense to me also i
noticed he didn't he didn't want to move
the conversation forward
yeah he just wanted to stay with that
only for whatever reason well he's a
facts type of a guy he likes to gather
information
and he didn't sound like he wanted to
get into
why he supports
why he didn't support trump why he
didn't why he thought that those
organizations were good
because you talked about how they were
evil right and you asked if if there
were any good ones and he said i don't
see the point in talking about that